hi I'm lur Nichols coming from Eugene
Oregon so I'm going to be bending my POI
in wall plane here's what one POI
bending in wall plane looks
like it's bending around the front back
axis which is where our hands move when
they move in wall plane they're rotating
around the front back axis so here it is
in wheel plane here it is in floor plane
back to wheel plane and back to floor
plane I'm going to be moving from
forward bending I'm going to end up
reverse bending and come back to
forward I can bend the poy clockwise to
me counterclockwise to you or I can bend
the
poy counterclockwise to me and clockwise
to
you as I'm bending my my POI is going to
move from one side of the arm and if I
keep bending it's going to have to move
to the other side of the
arm okay so here's what I'm going to
show you is plane bending in different
timings and directions let's start with
the most basic timing and direction is
together same with the hands it looks
like
this with the props it looks like this
and with plain
bending it looks like
[Music]
this so there's four basic timing and
directions there's together
same there's split
opposite there's split same
and there's together
opposite but we can also bend the poy in
each of those timing and directions two
different ways so there's eight total
basic bends in wall plane so together
same bending and Wall playing
so our po go from vertical to diagonal
to horizontal to diagonal to Vertical to
diagonal in this one my PO are both
rotating away from the body together or
toward the body together the other way
of doing it is for one po rotating
toward my body and one rotating away
from the
side this one's rotating toward and then
away this one's rotating away and then
toward so we had both away both toward
both away both toward and now we have
one toward one away one toward one away
one toward one away one away one I'll
turn it back to you
now and we're going to bend in the same
direction both po bending in the same
direction trying to keep having those po
hit the outsides
at the same time boom boom boom boom
boom boom bo do split same toward away
looks really
simple split same T
[Music]
away way and again I can bend one way
or the other
way split same toward toward is
interesting so from the side it's going
to look like this you're split opposite
sort of oscillating front back front
back
oscillation split split split split
oscillation front back
yeah oscillation front back split split
split split on the Y on the up down
oscillation front back oscillation front
back and you end up with this Bend
Kabam
kizzle
boom
boom with opposite direction bending our
po end up in atomic which means that the
PO are going in two different planes so
here we have together
same wheel plane we're bending in the
opposite
direction we end up in this Atomic with
the front back axis as the the axis of
intersection where the two planes
intersect is the front back axis yeah so
we're oscillating front
back to bend it up into
this if we keep bending it ends up
looking like this
so this is together opposite bending
with both going toward or away yeah
they're both away both toward both away
both toward now we're going to do
together opposite with one moving away
and one moving toward and I've got my
right hand
moving forward and my left hand moving
backward I'm going to put my right hand
on top of my left hand
and bend into split
[Music]
same split opposite both toward both
away both away both T both away both T
both away both toward both way both
toward and then and then they're going
to bend in the opposite
direction and you get into
this one more is a split opposite this
is probably the easiest of all the
opposite direction bending so it's a
good one to start with in this one we're
in Split same wheel plane I'm going to
try and rotate that back towards you and
then I'm going to bend them the opposite
direction into try and do it slowly for
[Music]
everyone so that's it that's eight basic
bends